*Respire fort*
...Ça va pas
*Gémissement*
J'ai mal au crâne, putain !
Depuis qu'on a sortit le clip avec Maxenss
vous arrêtez pas de nous
faire des compliments et...
TAHHHHH!
J'ai pris la grosse tête !
Ok, Ok, Ok ! On arrête les bêtises!
Il est vrai, vos avis sont  positifs et il est vrai j'aime pas avoir la grosse tête.
Alors j'ai besoin qu'on me casse en deux
Okay j'ai fait un petit tweet en vous demandant de me clasher intelligemment
pour remédier à ce problème de grosse tête,
pour équilibrer la balance entre les compliments et les insultes bien evidemment
Nyo qui nous dit " Ton visage on dirait un chameau "
Merci Nyo
On ne refera plus jamais de vidéos ensemble
"Tu te prends pour un dalton avec tes bottes et ton stetson"
"Mais laisses moi te rappeler que ton nom est Personne !"
Oh c'est bien trouvé ça
"Tu te prends pour un dalton avec tes bottes et ton stetson"
"Mais laisses moi te rappeler que ton nom est Personne !"
ahhhhh! ça plagie, ça plagie !
Allez même on fait toute la chanson, vraiment toute la chanson tous ensemble c'est mignon vous êtes mignons !
OH ! j'ai la grosse tête, ok
Faut m'clacher là,
Faut pas me provoquer des réactions
Comme ça, de minion
"Ta masse musculaire fait le poids de mon petit cousin prématuré"
* sourit *
ça attaque sur le physique
Tout de suite, nan mais voilà!
franchement, ça vole pas haut Heinn..
Taaain, la bâtarde !
"Tes vidéos c'est de la merde, arrête youtube steuplait
mer..meeeerki...merci"
Ahh, ça me fait redescendre
Ah, je sens que je redescends, continuez !!!
"Lucas je regarde tes vidéos depuis 4 ans et ta puberté n'est toujours pas arrivée"
"Et la barbe ?"
"Je la soupçonne d'être une fausse barbe mdrr"
Ohh ouii continuez !
"Prends pas trop la grosse tête ! Ça paraîtra difforme à côté de ton corps de lâche."
Est-ce qu'on fait tout de suite toutes les vannes qui concernent mon corps de lâche ?
Ça sera plus simple.
On les fait toutes d'affilée comme ça on fait le festival des vannes sur le corps de lâche de Squeezie,
c'est parti c'est maintenant !
"Au moins ta tête te fera peut-être atteindre le mètre 70, p'tit con"
"Malgré ta barbe tu 'es pas encore viril, jeune corps de lâcheeeeee"
"Tu vas pas redescendre de bien haut vu ta taille" *ricanement*
"T'as peut-être la grosse tête mais tes bras sont toujours aussi petits, smiley tire la langue"
"Ah parce qu'elle était pas déjà grosse ta tête ?"
Sympa ça, sympa.
Désolé Squeezie mais si tu prends la grosse tête avec ton corps en tige tu
penses pas que ça va faire coton tige.. bruh"
C'est nul, c'est nul
Squeezie avec la grosse tête ça ressemble à une figurine POP.
*rires* Ah l'batard, ça c'est moi, c'est parfaitement moi, hier soir en lisant vos commentaires
sur la vidéo sur le clip, j'étais vraiment comme ça, c'est les réelles proportions !
Putain ils sont drôles ces abonnés c'est fou.
"Ton flow est comme le muscle de ton bras droit. Plat"
C'est blessant !
"T'as les bras de Bob l'éponge"
Ouais ! Et alors ?
N'oublie pas que j'ai doublé une mouette dans ce film et je sais très bien qu'il y a une image où il
possède, d'énormes bras musclés !
*rire démoniaque*
Non ! Putain
"T'es tellement maigre que quand tu montes sur la balance y'a écrit :
Veuillez monter sur la balance"
Ah je la connaissait pas cette blague elle est originale *ricanement*
"Tu es tellement moche que quand tu fais du stop personne s'arrête" *rires*
Eh vous êtes chauds là ! Eh tranquille aussi un peu là
"Ta barbe elle a des trous"
Simple, mais pourtant si efficace.
"J'ai rien à ajouter de plus"
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a, qu'est-ce qu'il y a maintenant ?!
"Visiblement ça commence à pousser dur à la salle! Bibis et début de pecs, fier de toi !"
Ah c'est bon ! *rires* Le festival est terminé, merci à tous d'être venus..
"Rappelles-toi les vidéos de 2010"
Nan Alban Alban Alban j'trouve que c'est un peu petit d'en arriver là déjà
*ancienne vidéo de Squeezie*
Parce que, ma vidéo sur despeS2 (?) j'ai pas pu la sortir
dans les temps...
Euhhh...Alors que c'était la vidéo spéciale 200 abonnés
Et qu'on est presque à 300 abonnés !
*souffle*
*bruit de coup de feu*
Ohhhh Bérénice Touzet qui est très mignon !
"Pourquoi clasher quand une musique est aussi agréable à écouter ?"
*cri*
Nan arrêtez ! Arrêtez arrêtez arrêtez !
Vous avez vu ce qui m'arrive quand je vois ça ! C'est chaud !
"Tes tatouages c'est comme ta vie on peut les effacer facilement"
J'crois que t'as pas compris le principe du tatouage Vole de mort
Oh ! "Pour une fois que tu t'éloignes du style de Pewdiepie c'est pour t’immiscer dans celui de Maxenss"
Bouuuummmmmmmm !
Lourd putain il est en tête du classement !
"Fais gaffe que ta tête se gonfle pas à l'hélium, sinon y'a pas que ta modestie qui va s'envoler"
Putain c'est horrible parce que c'est très recherché, mais c'est quand même nul
*rire*
"Pire forceur au monde"
Ah putain ça me met mal là tous ces.. toutes ces insultes
"Tes podcasts étaient tellement nuls que tu t'es reconverti dans le gaming popopo"
Quels podcasts ? Il y a pas de podcasts j'ai jamais fait de podcasts
"Yo tout le monde c'est Squeezie, on se retrouve aujourd'hui pour mon tout premier podcast raaaighhht..
C'est pas moi, c'est pas moi ça ! C'est...
Est-ce que je ressemble déjà ? Non.
Bah c'est pas moi !
*rires* "Les jaloux diront Photoshop, j'ai rien à rajouter sinon"
Si j'avais su un jour qu'en faisant cette pose sur des barres parallèles, des gens me rajouteraient
"Ma bite est plus grosse que ton soit disant talent en chant"
Putain, elle doit être énorme hein ! PS : J'suis un fille.
Oh non !
"Message à tous les con qui se croient au dessus des autres regarder votre vie avant de parler de Lucas bandes de macaques"
Mais non mais...!
Mais Hayet Rami Kami... t'énerve pas c'est le but de cette vidéo ! J'ai demandé !
Y'a trop d'amour dans cette communauté, j'trouve ça beau ! J'trouve ça beau.
Franchement j'aime bien.
"t'es trop nul"
Oh putain Laink Mec, franchement t'es un batard de dire ça devant tout l'monde.
C'est blessant tu vois
Quand j'te dis des trucs comme ça quand on est que tous les deux
Tu les répète pas en public s'il te plait !
Franchement c'est relou :)
Bon... Oh vous avez vu comme j'ai réussi à casser l'ambiance avec mon jeu d'acteur de merde
C'était beau, c'était beau, c'était beau, c'était beau, c'était beau.
Ficello... Achetez-en.
"J'ai toujours préféré MonsieurDream (Cyprien)
Moi aussi moi aussi Mec,
"Maxenss te défonce au bras de fer."
Ouais, *Rires*
Pas d'argument !
"T'es qui?"
Micka ?! MICKA ?!
C'est toi qui a pris la grosse tête là, à m'dire t'es qui ?!
Putain avec tes 23ans de conneries ! Fan de jeux vidéos,Disney Streamer de 12h à 12h01 !
Code Promo "Mickalow" pour le 1er mois.
Quoi ?!
Tu es un vendu ? Tu fait des vrais placement ?!
*Rires*
t'es tellement pas respecté que quand t'es passé en arrière
dans la vidéo de tontonmcfly et raphael carlier j'ai cru que t'etais un stagiaire
OHHHHH
Merde alors !
Nan par contre j'aurais kiffé faire un stage euh comme ça hein.
Ah mec, j'peux te dire que mon stage je l'ai fait a intermarché
mon gars, il faisait -5 degrès
On devait ouvrir les packs en plastique avec nos doigts
parce qu'ils voulaient pas nous lâcher de cutter
par peur qu'on se blesse.
Du coup on s'blessais encore plus que si on avait vraiment un cutter !
Vous avez vu c'est le vécu qui parle.
"T'es qu'un sale daltonien !"
*Rires* Oh putain !
Ah le mec il est... ok,
Il a joué le jeu il s'est moqué des handicapés
il veut que les gens l'aiment pas Mais c'est pas... il a joué le jeu ok.
"Chien errant" *Rires*
La violence t'sais c'est pas recherché mais ça passe crème l'insulte gratuite.
"Ce mec est sado maso ou il fait une vidéo
en tout cas sa dernière musique était grave cool."
Merci mec c'est sympa !
"aussi cool que JUL"
*WASTED*
"Tous ces pouces bleus que tu croyais avoir, il étaient rouges
mais comme t'es un putain de daltonien tu croyais
faire des bonnes vidéos, con."
*Rires*
Franchement il y avait un bon fond
mais t'es parti dans un truc
qui n'est plus du français
du coup j'arrivais plus à comprendre ta phrase.
"Les gens en France t'ont tellement insulté que t'as décidé d'aller en Corée."
Ouais et alors ?!
J'ai intégré un groupe de KPop mon pote !
*Musique Kpop*
"Squeezie on dirait Cyprien mais avec moins de cheveux."
*Rires*
Eh il aura une calvitie avant moi vieux !
C'est sur il est plus vieux
Normalement il aura une calvitie avant moi !
Tu sens dans l'grain d'ma voix qu'au fond ça m'a blessé,
qu'au fond vous avez trouvés la p'tite faille,
la p'tite faille qui blesse vraiment Squeezie
En vrai c'est la calvitie que je montre.
"J'ai même pas vu l'clip" *Rires*
Oh l'bathard oh elle était bien celle là !
J'ai une bonne nouvelle les amis.
J'ai plus la grosse tête
C'est bon, vous m'avez calmé !
Vous m'avez calmés ma grosse race.
Y'a eu de tout là
Sur le physique...
Sur le physique !
C'était fou !
N'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si elle vous a plu
Je n'ai plus la grosse tête, je suis de nouveau comme avant ça m'fais plaisir.
J'pourrais dire au mecs qui m'dit "et change pas reste comme t'es."
T'inquiète j'avais changé mais j'ai fait ce qu'il faut et je suis re moi même.
"Ouais ta geule par contre."
Ok..
J'vous fait plein de bisous
en réalité je vous remercie pour
cet accueil exceptionnel pour la vidéo euh
Placement d'produits.
C'est juste dinque
On était trop contents avec Maxenss
Toute l'équipe était trop contente
Ils ont vu aussi tout ce que vous avez dit
Merci pour tout ! et puis je vous dit à très vite
dans une prochaine vidéo !
bien sur avec une voix, bien sur d'animateur de fête foraine.
Et attention c'est parti on lance l'attraction
3, 2,1 let's gooo!
Les sous-titres étaient longs à faire... Merci d'avoir activés les sous-titres !  : Lili01230 !